- Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
Thank you for coming to
the 61st annual Edward
H. Hume Memorial Lecture.
We're really happy to have you here,
partly because we did not
do this lecture last year
due to COVID,
so this is a bit of a reopening for us
and we're really especially
happy to see you.
You can learn more about Dr. Hume
in the back of your brochure here.
He was a physician,
he was a Yale College graduate.
He spent a good part
of his career in China,
where he founded this Hsiang-Ya Hospital
and medical school,
and has a connection to
the Yale-China association.
I think some of our Yale-China
association friends are
here tonight.
But yes, as I said,
we're very happy to have you.
I know a few people are
still making their way in.
Please note this lecture
is being recorded.
So if you ask a question,
you may show up on the audio,
which will be posted
to our YouTube channel.
Afterwards, if you know
anybody who missed it,
please let them know
that it's being recorded
and will be posted.
And so, yeah, without further ado,
I will turn it over to Arne Westad,
the Elihu Professor of History,
who will introduce our guest speaker.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Richard.
So it's a great pleasure
for me to introduce
my friend, Professor Rana Mitter,
who is going to be speaking to us today
for the 61st Hume lecture,
with a title like "Kite
Flies Against The Wind:
"Internationalism, Identity and Ideology
"in the Shaping of Postwar China
"and a Legacy for Today."
So Rana is professor
of history and politics
of Modern China at Oxford University.
He's a fellow of St. Cross College.
He was inaugural director
of the Oxford China Center
from 2013 to 2020,
when he made his escape from that one
in order to do more books, I'm sure.
He has done quite a few already.
I'm not gonna mention
all of them here, Rana,
but I'm just gonna highlight
some of those that have been
particularly influential
in terms of Professor Mitter's work.
"A Bitter Revolution:
"China's Struggle with the Modern World,"
which is his survey of 20th century China,
and probably the best one
that is available now,
was published in 2004.
His book, "Forgotten Ally,"
as it was published
under the title of here.
"Forgotten Ally: China's World War II,"
published in 2013,
is certainly the most
distinguished history
of China's World War II.
"The Anti-Japanese War,"
as most Chinese will know it as.
And one that had a tremendous reception
when it came out.
And most recently, a book
entitled "China's Good War:
"How World War II is
Shaping a New Nationalism,"
which came out now almost two years ago.
Now, that last book, I think,
sets some of the background
for the lecture today,
at least in terms of some
of the questions asked.
And I must say when I read that book,
I saw it as a tremendous success
because it was able to do
many things at the same time.
It was able to present an updated history
of how many Chinese
view Anti-Japanese War,
we know as the Second World War,
but it was also able to deal
with memory and identification,
and project that forward to today
in terms of how the memory of that war
and the identity is created
by that play and inference...
Have a strong influence today.
Our colleague here at Yale,
Jay Winter,
wrote in a review of the book,
that "Mitter shows movingly
what Chinese people sing about
"and weep about
"when they turn their minds to
"the devastating contours
of the Second World War.
"Equally at home in provincial museums,
"internet chat rooms,
"and China's foreign ministry,
"Mitter is a sure guide to
this ongoing reassessment
"of the war and postwar.
"His brilliant account," Jay says,
"shows how nation has replaced class
"in the moral narrative
China has constructed
"to frame its national project."
And I think that's a
really good summing up
of the strengths and the
significance of the book.
So Rana, in his work,
is, first and foremost,
I would argue, a student
of Chinese nationalism
in its various forms,
starting out with his
early work on Manchuria,
and then going all the way up to his work
on Chinese politics in the 21st century.
And as many people, he will know,
some better than me,
dealing with concepts of
Chinese nationalism is
a really difficult topic,
and I'm sure we are going to
hear more about that today.
Rana has really put his stamp on
the historical discussion,
and historiographical discussion,
but also the contemporary discussion,
about the format, the significance,
and the role of Chinese nationalism.
And he's been able to do that
because he's not just an historian doing
fantastic work at Oxford,
Rana is also a leading
British public intellectual,
not just on issues relating to China,
but on issues of history
and contemporary international
affairs in general.
And the impact that he has had
on this has been tremendous.
Having taught in Britain
for a very long time,
and even after coming to this country,
I'm amazed to see how many
people you've influenced,
including a lot of people
who do not work on China,
in terms of how they understand
the contemporary world.
So we are really, very lucky
to have you working in this field.
I picked up...
Just before you came here,
I was trying to put together
this presentation, Rana,
and I found a recent interview with you
where you outlined how you
got interested in China
in the first place,
and I just wanted to quote
a bit of that in conclusion.
So you say in this interview,
"In the late 1980s and the early 1990s,
"China was a tremendously remote place
"in terms of British perceptions.
"India has always, for Imperial reasons,
"been the Asian connection
"that's been stronger in Britain.
"So this was a combination
of a very challenging
"but interesting language,"
I can certainly subscribe to that,
"but also a culture that perhaps had
"as little to do with the
things I've grown up with
"as could possibly be imagined.
"And although, in later decades,
"China has come much closer to us,
"that was by no means obvious.
"So it was a leap in the dark,
"but not one that I regretted
at any point since."
Well, neither have we, Rana,
who've followed you work
and learned from your work
over now, quite a long career
in the study of China.
I think it is a most fortuitous choice
that you made back then
for all of those of us who have benefited
from your writing,
from both your early books,
and the books that you
produced most recently.
It might not have been an
immediate choice at the time,
but it certainly was a good one.
So with that,
let us all welcome Professor
Rana Mitter to Yale.
(audience applauding)
- Before I do anything
else in this COVID age,
I should ask Richard,
is this bottle of water for my use?
Excellent, very good indeed.
Always best to check on these matters.
Could I start by saying thank you
very much to everyone who has come
in person to this event?
And I know these days that agreeing
to come in person to event has
its own frisson around it,
so I'm very grateful
that you've all chosen
to join us this this afternoon.
And could I also start, if I may,
with a couple of thanks?
I'm very grateful to the committee
who chose me to give the Edward
H. Hume Memorial Lecture.
I know, having looked
at some of the history,
that not only was Edward Hume himself
clearly one of the many
distinguished Yale graduates
who made their mark in
and connected to China,
but also I felt suitably
humbled by the range
of very distinguished scholars
who have given this beforehand.
So I am aware of the...
The honor that has done to me
by inviting me here for that.
I'd also like to thank
Richard Sosa, Stephanie Kim,
and all the others who have done
the rather complex arrangements
to actually bring someone
from Britain to America,
something which used to
be quite simple to arrange
but now has its own complexities.
I'd also like, if I may, to say, briefly,
a word to two scholars:
One is my very old friend,
Professor Arne Westad,
whose work, like, I think, frankly,
most of the field of modern
history have been learning
from the last 25 to 30 years.
Not to remind you, Arne about how long
you've been educating us all for,
but I think it is fair to say that
in terms of everything from
the history of postwar China,
a subject on which today
I'm going to touch with,
and I hope in some ways engage
with some of the agendas
that Arne has challenged
our field with,
but also well beyond that in terms
of the global Cold War,
and a whole variety of what we might call
"The History of our Own Era,"
a field in which, Arne, I think is
genuinely an unmatched historian.
His departure from the
UK a few years ago was
a great loss to us,
but it was an immense
gain not only to Yale,
but also I think to the wider field
on which he's now able to stride.
I'd also like to, if I may,
give a brief word to a
scholar who is not here,
but I think is here in a wider sense,
and that is of course
the late Jonathan Spence.
I only met Jonathan
Spence a couple of times.
One, I'm glad to say, was actually here
at Yale University when
he was kind enough to come
and listened to a talk that I gave,
but I have told many times before,
and will very briefly tell the story of,
in that early phase that Arne mentioned
when I was thinking, as
a school boy in England,
what subject I might wish
to study at university,
one of the books that fell to my hand...
In fact, the first book that I ever read
in Chinese history was "The
Gate of Heavenly Peace:
"The Chinese and Their Revolution,"
the sweeping panoramic story
of what I now think of...
I didn't know it then,
but what I now think of
is the May 4th generation
and the revolution that they made.
And I still have that rather
battered Penguin copy,
which I bought in a bookstore
in Brighton, England,
quite easily to hand in the
study that I have today,
I've realized, to my horror,
probably something like
three-and-a-half decades
after I bought it.
So although, of course,
Jonathan Spence is no longer
with us here at Yale,
he is, of course, someone
whose reputation will live
for a very long time in the field,
and I'm personally very glad
to have learned from him also.
So a lot to live up to today
and I will do my best, but forgive me if,
following in the footsteps
of various giants,
I may stumble now and then.
But I think we should start, if I may,
with some of the bigger events
that have been shaping understanding
of Chinese history in the
last few weeks and months
before we return to a
period slightly longer ago.
And this is where I hope that
the technology is going to
allow us to follow this.
Yes, there we are.
Particularly in this audience,
you may have paid some attention to
the promulgation of the resolution
on certain questions
in the Party's history
that was passed through the Sixth plenum
of the Chinese Communist Party in Beijing,
and officially announced
just a few months ago.
In fact, in November of 2021.
You will have seen, if so,
that the resolution does certain things.
It seals the historical status,
as one sees in the posters here,
of Xi Jinping as China's leader,
placing him in a very direct
and high profile trajectory
from Mao Zedong through Deng Xiaoping,
again, all of them portrayed
as you see there in the
poster on the right hand side,
and then through the other leaders,
Jiang Zemin, Hu Jintao, onto Xi Jinping.
Those two previous leaders
though, Mao and Deng,
were the only ones associated with
previous such resolutions
in the party's history.
One was, of course, the more recent,
Deng Xiaoping, back in 1981,
just 40 or 41 years ago,
whose resolution essentially was
an admission of at least
partial responsibility
for the Cultural Revolution.
But the previous resolution,
all the way back in 1945,
was promulgated just as the
war with Japan was coming
to an end,
and it helped Mao Zedong to confirm
the leadership of his party,
which had been a work in process
but very much consolidating by that time.
And that, of course, was a resolution
that also laid down the ground
even before the civil war that
would eventually bring Mao
and his party to victory.
And I want to turn back
to that date in particular, to 1945,
and talk a little bit about how I think
that that moment should be rediscovered
in terms of understanding not only,
I think, some of the significance of
the history of that moment,
but also where it links
to the present day.
And I want to do that by putting forward
an argument that the
factors that underpinned
the struggle for order
and the means of achieving that order have
important parallels for a story
that emerges at that time,
but which we are still living with
in a different form in the present day.
And that is the story of
the rise of a global China,
and a China that thinks about itself
and thinks about its place in the world
in some particular ways.
And for reasons of
organization and convenience,
but I hope ones that will make some sense,
I've divided that into
three areas of examination,
all of which conveniently
begin with the letter, "I":
Internationalism, ideology, and identity.
And the moment, the period, the era
in which I want to place them is
a period that I started to
call "The Chinese Postwar."
This is, of course, a reference
to the years after World War II,
but it's also attempt
to try and popularize
the use of the term "postwar,"
in other words, post-Second World War,
post Anti-Japanese War,
in the Chinese context
in a way that is entirely mainstream
and uncontroversial in
the European context,
as the late Tony Judt, for one,
would've put forward,
and, of course, in the
(speaking foreign language)
in the Jap...
Sorry, the Japan history field,
where it's been a well known term.
The Chinese equivalent,
(speaking foreign language),
has, of course, existed for a long time
but it doesn't have quite, I think,
the capacity to encompass a range of ideas
about a period
as opposed to a literal
statement of the period itself
in a way that there's other terms do.
And so, I am putting it
forward at this point.
It is, of course,
a period about which
Arno Westad has written
with immense distinction,
the period of the Chinese Civil War,
1946 to 1950.
And if you didn't think
the Chinese Civil War went on until 1950,
you should check out Hainan Island,
where of course it did last
until quite late into that year.
But I would say that also, of course,
it is much more than the period
of the Chinese Civil War,
devastating and central though that was.
It was also the time when China moved
into the first phase of its engagement
with the postwar international order.
And I speak, of course,
today on a day when,
largely to do with
events in Eastern Europe
rather than East Asia,
the nature of that postwar order,
already somewhat fragile for good reasons,
is becoming even more in question
as the hours and the days go by.
It's also, of course, a
moment when China sought
a new definition of its own sovereignty
as a founder member of the United Nations.
And of course, a permanent member
of the newly formed Security Council.
It was also a time when
China became embroiled
in some of the biggest global debates
about the links between
economic and social development.
It was also a time when
ideological concerns did,
I think, come to the forefront.
There were huge debates in China
in those postwar years
about what democracy might actually mean
in the Chinese context.
And of course, huge debates
about what relationship, if any,
that type of democracy had
to the growing, and
ultimately inexorable forces,
in China's deep countryside.
In other words,
it was a time when some
of the debates were
remarkably similar to those of today,
and in other important ways,
remarkably different.
The China of Xi Jinping,
I should be clear,
is not, in any argument that I will make,
the same has the China that
Mao Zedong took over in 1949.
Today's China is global in reach,
whereas that China was recovering
from the aftermath of two huge wars:
First with Japan and then, of course,
between the Chinese themselves.
Today's China is, I think, indubitably
a consumerist society,
the earlier version was
very much about austerity.
Today's China is an
innovator in technology,
that earlier version was
desperate to find support,
whether from the Soviets
or from the Americans,
to create its own ecology of development
that will become autonomous over time
but could not start in that way.
So the differences are clear,
but the continuities do matter.
To understand why that would be,
you just have to look at the process
that was going on to produce
the resolution on the party's history.
And the key word in that,
perhaps unsurprisingly,
is the word "history."
In other words, the CCP,
the Chinese Communist Party,
cares deeply that its own version
of its own story of origin is dominant
without any of the
nasty bumps in the road,
vicious intra-party massacres,
the famine of the Great Leap Forward,
the turmoil of the Culture Revolution,
that in practice have been
part of the historical nexus
of events that have brought it to power.
And you can see that,
I won't go through the whole thing,
you'll be glad to know,
but here are a few key quotes from
the authorized English translation
of the original text as issued.
And I go into that detail because
although we have a relatively
limited time today,
I think it is fair to say
that that history is becoming
of increasing interest
both in China itself
and in the wider world.
And actually, in some ways,
the interest is a bifurcated one.
One is a series of questions of interest
within the historical profession,
and in today's comments,
when I get to some
detail in just a moment,
I think it is fair to say
that those debates are ones
that I think historians are
primarily concerned with,
and which I think can help
us rethink, beyond China,
this period of global history.
But the other set of concerns is
very much an engagement with the idea
that shape China's contemporary politics,
and I give you this short,
if somewhat dense, extract
from the party resolution of 2021,
simply to point out the
Chinese Communist Party
in its present incarnation,
however future-oriented,
however keen it is on creating
a forward-looking socioeconomic contract,
is still immensely concerned with the way
in which it's past is constructed
in its own eyes
and in the eyes of others.
So to give you some illustration
of how that continuity,
as well as change, works,
I've drawn on historical
materials relating
to various individuals with, I think,
important insights into the geopolitical
and ideological change during that period.
I'm not gonna talk today very much
about the very, what
you might kind of call,
top tier of leaders,
Mao Zedong, Chiang Kai-Shek, and others.
I've written about them elsewhere,
and there are many others
who have done wonderful work
on what they were doing
during this period.
Instead, I want to draw on some voices
that I think are less well known,
although I think they are quite central
in terms of what they illustrate
to the dynamics of that
postwar moment in China.
And I have to confess,
I've chosen them also because
they allowed me to indulge
what I personally have found
one of the most rewarding parts
of examination of historical development
during this time,
which is the diaries kept by
very large numbers of figures,
not only of world historical importance,
but also quite local,
inward-looking importance.
Day after day, I think
here Arne may agree,
that historians of China give thanks for
the Confucian tendencies
that led very large numbers of Chinese,
even into the mid 20th century,
to keep very extensive diaries
of their own thoughts and doings,
and those have been very
valuable to all of us
who want to reconstruct
that particular past.
And I will here show a couple of pictures
of two of the figures
who I wanted to bring up,
or will bring up.
On the left hand side, a figure,
I've said he was less famous
than some of the others
but actually, at the time,
pretty distinguished, Wang Shijie.
During the time that I'm talking about,
the foreign minister of China,
but also a constitutional lawyer.
One of that extraordinary
generation of young Chinese,
almost all, but not entirely,
but almost all men who were
sent to study overseas,
mostly in the United States,
some of them in Britain,
and who became fluent not
just in English and Chinese,
but actually fluent
into worldviews as well.
And I think that that is something which,
until recently, has been forgotten
and perhaps underappreciated.
On the right hand side,
drawing actually here
on memoirs rather than diaries,
but I think very, very
vivid ones in many ways,
is Zeng Zhi.
During the post-war years,
she was a young communist activist.
She joined the revolution
when she was just 15 years old
in Hunan province.
She spent most of the next 20 years
essentially on the run.
She was a powerful actor in her own right,
but I should observe,
she also became married
to a figure who became
very senior in the CCP,
Politburo Standing
Committee Member, Tao Zhu,
who came to a pretty harrowing end
during the Cultural Revolution, in fact.
And these figures I
think are amongst those
who illustrate some of the wider points
that I wanted to make.
Wang Shijie himself, as he
observed in his diaries,
the period of, first of all, hope
and then despair of the last years
of the Kuomintang
nationalists in government.
As first of all, observing a period where
all sorts of new possibilities
had opened up for China,
but also one where the
country was deeply vulnerable.
Bear in mind that in 1945,
at the time of the Japanese surrender,
China was simultaneously both stronger
and weaker than it had been at any time
in a century.
Stronger, because it had the prestige
of being a victorious Allied power
alongside the British, the
Americans, the Soviets,
and, of course, the French;
and full sovereignty,
essentially for the first time since 1843,
because of wartime treaties
that had been signed to
end various restrictions
on its sovereignty.
But at the same time,
weak beyond imagining
because it was a country that,
over the eight years of the
war against the Japanese,
had been destroyed by bombing,
refugee flight, and financial
and economic disaster.
Zeng Zhi and other comrades of hers saw
this postwar period as a time
of ideological refashioning,
when previous assumptions
about mentalities had
to be rethought.
It was not enough to rebuild
China's railways and roads,
you had to refashion its people as well.
And today, the reason I
bring this up is that,
today, it's become quite commonplace
to look at much of China's language,
political language, official language,
particularly at a time
when it really matters
to know what the official
mind of China thinks and says.
And from a Western point of view,
quite often, that language,
particularly when translated
directly into English,
sounds either highly laden with jargon
or very saccharine,
or very, very confrontational,
or indeed aggressive.
And one of the things
that I think going back
to some of that period
of birth and development
of that sort of political language is
a reminder that yes,
it is highly constructed language,
but that does not make
it inauthentic language.
And I think the connection
between those two is
very important in terms of understanding
what people at that time
thought they were doing
rather than what we think
they may have been doing at the time,
as I will hope to show.
You early on in his tenure
as foreign minister,
he served from 1945, August, to 1948,
Wang Shijie became part of
the Chinese negotiation team
with none other than the man
that Arne calls "the boss"
in his books, Joseph Stalin.
It was pretty much a baptism,
if it was a baptism of sorts, of fire.
Imagine your first
diplomatic negotiation being
with Stalin the other end.
Wang Shijie knew that it was going to be
a pretty fierce sort of encounter,
and as he got on the
plane to head to Moscow,
he kept a little phrase that
his daughter had written for him.
And although the diaries
are in Chinese, a few...
He was a fluent speaker of English
and some phrases were in English.
And this one, his
daughter had also written
in English for him,
and that was the phrase,
"Don't be afraid of opposition.
"Remember, a kite flies against,
"not with, the wind."
And that was the source
of my title for today,
but I chose it because I think it was
a very appropriate metaphor for
an immensely turbulent time.
Let me...
Before I start getting
into some of the detail
of what Wang Shijie, Zeng Zhi,
and others were saying at this time,
I'm sure with this expert audience,
we don't need much of this,
but let me take about 90 seconds, I hope,
just to give a very, very quick overview
of some of the milestones, historically,
that we see in China during this time.
And as I've said, but will say again,
if you want more details,
you can't do better than to check out,
"Cold War and Revolution"
and "Decisive Encounters,"
two books by Arne, who has
pioneered this particular field.
But during those five
very, very crowded years,
it's worth noting that the war,
which China had fought
with Japan since 1937,
came to an end;
Negotiations between the
nationalists, the Kuomintang,
and the Soviets led to a
Sino-Soviet Treaty of Friendship
in August, 1945
that was essentially an
attempt, amongst other things,
by the Chinese nationalists
to close off the Soviets,
to give them certain concessions
in return for them not attempting
further support of their
Communist Chinese allies
or further territorial demands,
which include, of course at that time,
incursions into Xinjiang
as well as into Manchuria;
China also during this becomes one of
the permanent five members
of the UN Security Council.
China, of course, has been permanently
on that council ever since,
although, of course, for a
couple of decades as Taiwan,
rather than as the mainland, until 1971;
And also during this time,
you see the increasingly
fraught coalition negotiations
that begin in 1945-46.
General Marshall, George
Marshall, spent most of 1946,
ultimately vainly, trying to get
a ceasefire and coalition government
between the communists and nationalists,
before that broke down;
You then have 1946 to '49,
a vicious civil war between the two sides.
At first, there was a plausible argument
that the Kuomintang,
that the nationalists,
could somehow consolidate and destroy
the CCP's political and military base,
but a variety of factors turned the tide.
Everything from improved
communist battle tactics
under Lin Biao and others,
to the destruction of the morale
and economic base of the Kuomintang
through poor military
choices and economic chaos.
Eventually, the end of the story,
of course, is well known.
Chiang Kai-Shek flee to Taiwan
and the communists conquer
the mainland by 1949,
with Hainan Island
following the next year.
So that is the main
narrative of the Civil War
and the immensely important
backdrop to other events.
But I want to put that,
if one can do that,
slightly aside for a little bit,
because it seems to me
that we sometimes act
as if a phase in China's
foreign relations ends in 1949
and starts again from zero.
So from Mao's China,
the turn to the Soviet Union,
the split from the
United States made final
by the Korean War,
and the continued
presence of the ROC Taiwan
in the United Nations until the 1970s.
And in that version of history,
I'm caricaturing slightly,
but not all that much in some ways,
1945 to '49 is a sort of stub,
it's an afterthought,
it's unfinished business
that finally gets wrapped up
but isn't of huge
importance in its own right.
And I'd wanna challenge that.
I think although a lot did start again,
evidently, in 1949,
some important elements,
including China's engagement
with the United Nations
and the rivalry between
Taipei and Beijing,
which emerged to make links
with other non-Western states,
remained highly relevant
across that 1949 boundary.
And what makes Wang Shijie,
the foreign minister of China,
interesting in that time is
the thread of things being taken up,
or being set up,
that would not be taken up by him in
the immediate short term,
but would later come back to become
a very important part of
China's self-presentation
in that later era of global engagement
under the CCP.
I'm talking about territorial claims,
maritime and land based,
and the wider projection of China
as a power with regional
and even global ambitions.
So in his first year
in office, 1945 to '46,
Wang Shijie became part of
at least three major negotiations.
The first was the meeting
with Stalin in Moscow
to bring about the
Sino-Soviet treaty of 1945;
The second was his presence as part
of that team negotiating
with American support
for the coalition government
between the Communists
and the Nationalists;
But the third set of discussions related
to areas that have been less covered
and analyzed up to now,
and they relate in particular
to Wang Shijie's attempts,
at a fluid time in geopolitics,
to stake a claim for
China as a global player
in the postwar world.
To steal the famous words
of US Secretary of State, Dean Acheson,
slightly (murmurs),
he wasn't actually Secretary
of State at that point,
"Not just to be present at the creation,
"but also to take a stronger
role in doing the creating
"of an order that would
stretch across continents."
Bear in mind that Wang Shijie,
like most Chinese officials and elites,
whether Nationalists or Communist,
absolutely believe that
China's titanic sacrifices,
including the 10 million or more war dead
through a variety of causes,
military death, of course,
but famine and disease as well,
and of course, China's
refusal to surrender
to Japan in 1938,
their belief that these
events had changed the war
and that the world now had
a debt of honor to China.
And this led to a whole
variety of approaches,
some at the more seemingly quixotic end
of what might be geopolitically possible.
In other words, Wang's pushing of the idea
of China being a power that
might not just reshape Asia,
and I'll say more about that in a moment,
but also Europe as well.
And Wang Shijie pushed
repeatedly for China
to get a place at that table
of European negotiation.
That was, as I say,
at the further end of his ambition
at the time.
More achievable in the short term was
a desire to find a new mode of engagement
with other countries in the emergent
non-Western post-colonial world.
China saw itself potentially
as a mentor to many of them,
but also, of course,
in the case of countries
like India, in particular,
a rival or an alternative leader.
And Wang's daily negotiations
show many aspects of those,
as we will see.
The principle that
if the west could still make decisions
for Asia in 1945,
as indeed it was doing
in Vietnam, in Malaya,
in a whole variety...
In Korea, in a whole variety of other...
In Japan, indeed,
of polities in the region,
then likewise,
Asia should be able to have a role
in shaping the West.
It might seem, as I say,
an ambition beyond anything
that was realistic,
but it's logic clearly appealed deeply
to Wang Shijie's mind and, indeed, heart.
And that led him, I will say,
to some rather awkward conversations.
One is illustrated, as it were, here
in his engagement with the
then Soviet foreign
minister, Vyacheslav Molotov.
If you think that the current
foreign minister of Russia,
Serge Lavrov, is something of a hard case,
Molotov clearly set the mold.
And I think, in fact, he's
related through family too.
Marriage to the grandson, I think,
or something that...
Anyway, so there's a family
connection between the two,
it must be said.
And arriving in September 1945
at the London Foreign
Ministers' Conference,
one of Wang Shijie's first
priorities was to try
and grab some of the big
foreign ministers of that time.
Ernest Bevin of Britain,
James Burns, the Secretary of
State of the United States,
and Molotov.
He didn't get very far with them,
but nonetheless he
pressed his case strongly
where he felt he could do so.
Pushing the case, for instance,
with Molotov that a trusteeship
for the North African
colonies, such as Libya,
which had been left behind by Italy,
should be discussed in a much more open
and full way than was
being planned at the time.
And also, various plans
for the joint management,
potentially, of the
governance of postwar Japan.
Molotov was very keen on that idea.
Wang Shijie cooled on it quite quickly,
realizing that to do so would
almost certainly alienate
the United States,
but it was by no means a foolish request
on the part of Molotov,
since he could clearly
see the attractiveness
of putting forward an option
that would give the
Soviet more say in Japan,
but would also attract
China by giving them a role
as opposed to everything
essentially being decided
by the United States.
It's clear also from the negotiations
as recorded, that Wang
Shijie put forward viewpoints
and thoughts that drew
very much from his own
and China's own experience
during the past two decades.
I think the memories of Manchuria
being invaded in 1931 were
very much in his mind when he argued
against proposal by the French
to separate off part of Northern Germany
in the post war negotiations.
Wang said in his diary,
"I said that it wasn't right.
"If the people who lived in
that region didn't desire
"to separate from Germany, then...
"If the people who lived in
that region didn't desire
"to separate from Germany.
"I talked about the
principle of nationalism,"
(speaking foreign language)
"which should not be neglected even
"on the territory of your enemy."
Now that's an interesting statement,
particularly for the foreign
minister of a country
that had suffered as much
as China had at that point,
but also a sign of the, I think,
genuinely quite forward-looking thinking
that was going on,
not about just what had happened,
in terms of the immense
destruction visited on China,
but what the world that was
coming was going to look like.
He also went on very explicitly to say,
his words, "China could not be excluded
"from discussions of
the Balkans or Italy."
I have to say Molotov's
reply was essentially,
"Oh yes, China can be excluded"
and indeed, pretty much
went on to do that.
But again, the point is that
Wang was not simply refusing
to put...
Taking what he could get.
He was very keen to make
sure that the was put forward
and that China's argument
that it should be a power
that at least had some say
in global matters beyond
the Asian sphere was
on the record.
At that point, it has to be said,
that Secretary Burns didn't
entirely resist the idea,
although part of that was clearly to do
with trying to make sure
that there was a balance
between the various powers,
all of whom wanted to get a certain role.
And China, inevitably of course,
was on the weaker end of
that particular spectrum.
The following year,
when the foreign ministers
met in Paris, in 1946,
Wang Shijie was forced by stage,
in a way that had been
less necessary in '45,
to talk about and, to
some extent, make excuses
for the continuing
failure of his government
to resolve the civil war situation.
But his earlier lobbying
did actually pay off,
and China, at this conference,
was given a certain
amount of time to speak
about the European situation.
One argued that the reparations
for peace treaties being
drawn up mustn't be too harsh
so as to avoid, as he put it,
"Reactionary forces in the
defeated countries reviving
"and democratic forces
being unable to rise."
And again, in a moment,
in a day, indeed,
when the anger of powers
that consider that
they have been placed outside
the international order is being felt
just across the Atlantic
in Europe at the moment,
we can see, once again, that
these sorts of sentiments
from 1945-46,
while, at some level,
clearly very much tied
to that historical moment,
are by no means absent,
in terms of that wider
principle of establishing order.
Now, my point here is not...
And there are various other things,
of course, he talked about,
including the question
of Italy's colonies,
the Soviet refusal to withdraw from Iran,
and a whole variety of other factors
that emerged at that time.
My point here is not that
China was a major actor
in shaping the Balkan
or Italian settlements,
clearly it wasn't.
I think that would be a point
of historical revisionism too far.
What I think is important is
the narrative of entitlement.
Whether or not he got what he wanted,
Wang Shijie, at that point,
saw no reason why he
should not make a claim
for China, as a wartime
Allied victorious power,
to be part of the establishment
of that global order.
And while the point of origin
and the point of justification is
in some ways different today,
the fact that today a rather
different China makes claims,
not just obviously in its own backyard,
but in new areas, including the Arctic,
does show that the idea of
China thinking of itself
as a power that has global reach is
something that has a much longer history
that is sometimes assumed
when the Belt and Road Initiative,
starting seven or eight years ago,
is thought of as a sort of year zero.
In other words, China's
policymakers saw this
as part of a trajectory,
which, at that time,
they were projecting into a world
that would continue,
from their point of view,
from the 1940s, 50s and beyond.
They did not know at that stage,
although they quickly found out,
that their own particular
world would come to an end
in 1949.
But it didn't mean of course that
their successors couldn't take advantage
of what they had to say.
And let me give an example
of something closer to home from China
and Wang Shijie's point of view
that I think makes the
point quite clearly.
Because while I put forward
Wang Shijie's attempts
to try and influence
the European settlement
as perhaps the furthest reach
that he might have tried
in terms of making a claim
for a new global China,
the Asian sphere was not only an area
where actually there was
much greater success,
even in a relatively short period,
but also one where the sponsoring powers,
and in particular, the United States,
were much happier to allow
a greater Chinese role.
And this became quite clear
in terms of the initiative that China took
in some areas where it felt that
it had newly earned rights.
So let's take Wang Shijie,
looking a little closer to home,
on the Xisha, the
Paracel Islands, in 1947.
Now, I bring this
particular subject up again
because, again, in this audience,
I think it's fair to say,
that you'll be aware that the problem
of Chinese claims on
the South China Sea is
by no means of only historical interest.
I will not say anything more about rights
or wrongs or yeses or nos
about any present day claims,
but I will read, if I may,
a short extract from his diary,
the 18th of January, 1947,
which says something about the way
in which Wang Shijie was
looking to put forward
a new narrative of China's rights in Asia.
In this case, pitched as
an anti-colonial move,
because the power that was, at that stage,
in the Chinese sites,
when it came to reposession
of the islands in this case,
was Colonial France,
which wanted to reclaim
these particular islands
essentially as part of
their Vietnamese colony.
And Wang Shijie wrote in his diary,
"We've always claimed
the Xisha archipelago
"as our territory,"
so there's grist to the
(indistinct) of today,
as PRC making historical
claims on on the seas.
But Wang Shijie continues,
"But we've never yet set up officials
"or sent workers to stay
there on a regular basis."
And again, in the
present day (indistinct),
there's lots of debates about whether
or not these islands have been inhabited
and having people actually live on them.
"The French government
recognizes it," he says,
"as Vietnamese territory.
"After Japan's surrender,
"we sent a small number of troops
"to the important island at the heart
"of the archipelago,"
it's called Woody Island,
"to occupy it.
"Recently, the French
have sent a military ship
"to the island to scare
our troops resident there.
"But after my intervention, they withdrew.
"This is going to be a dispute
between China and France."
Well, I could say that
last sentence probably has
not come out as being the
major historical element
that was ultimately of importance,
but all the rest of that
I think does indicate
the way in which the claims
and the desire to reorder the Asian sphere
that was in China's influence was
very much at the heart
of the Kuomintang project
in the immediate postwar,
well before the communist victory in 1949.
And that happened...
Again, it doesn't happen out of context.
It happens during months and years
when a whole variety of
different visitors come
to Nanjing, the Chinese capital,
to negotiate eight for
a new order in Asia.
In 1946, the former Thai prime
minister, Pridi Banomyong,
visits after the treaty with Thailand.
As Wang said, "the first
time an important key figure
"from Thailand has visited
China in this way."
April 1947 was quite busy.
Syngman Rhee came in from Korea.
As Wang said, "His thinking
is a bit conservative,"
which I think is a bit
of an understatement,
but it's a fair analysis,
"but his spirit of
struggle is very strong."
And he was rather a fan of Rhee.
And then, the Philippines,
despite the disputes over South China Sea,
more broadly speaking,
in this case, a treaty
of friendship is set up
between the Chinese and
the Philippines government
just after the Philippines
gain independence.
In other words, much more of
the configuration of order,
it's being done by Asians with
other Asians at this point
than has perhaps been appreciated.
Not to the exclusion of
the superpower conflict
that emerge at that time,
and not to the exclusion of
the horrific domestic turmoil
that is tearing China apart,
but at the same time,
and is the confluence of
these particular forces
that I think deserves further examination
in terms of their simultaneous actions.
So let me move on from
that point, if I may,
for the last section of what I want to do,
to talk about a rather
different area of engagement.
I have been ranging, in the
last quarter of an hour or so,
in terms of this attempt to try
and rewrite a little bit,
the geopolitical project of China
in this immediate postwar era.
But I now want to sort of almost zoom
in the other direction
and look very much inside hearts and minds
to understand what was going on
in terms of changing in political thinking
at this particular sense,
and that's where I bring
together what I've called
the other two I's:
The ideology and the
identity of what going on.
And again, not that everything
in the past should reflect the present,
but at a time when huge
amounts of effort is spent
on reading Chinese documents,
Chinese social media,
I should say, actually CSIS
in Washington, DC, I believe,
is just about to start a
major new online project
in terms of analysis of
key Chinese documents,
which has actually a very 1960s air to it,
for those of us know where the feel the...
Emerged from,
although I personally wasn't around,
I have to say, during
that particular moment.
But that idea, in other words,
that you can read an awful lot into
how people construct language,
particularly Marxist phrases and language,
is I think one that has a much longer
and very interesting history.
In other words, we know a
great deal about ideology
in terms of what was taught
to converts to a particular
ideological cause.
But sometimes, I think the missing link is
to see how detailed the socialization was
of that belief interlinks
to objective reality.
I realize I'm sounding quite Marxist here,
but what I meant was that
these linguistic changes
and ways of thinking do
not happen in a vacuum.
I mean, how could they happen in vacuum?
They happen in the context
of historical events
and people use political
terms and language,
constructed language that
comes from elsewhere,
shape their own lived,
subjective experience.
And terms like "lived
subjecting experience,"
again, jargon for academics.
We are talking here about
extraordinary people.
Let's go back Zeng Zhi, who I
showed you at the beginning.
So, as I said, at the age of 15, in 1926,
she went on to a turbul...
She joined a turbulent
life that went on and on
in underground CCP politics.
In her own words,
she was "a career revolutionary."
She killed her first landlord with a spear
through her stomach in 1927.
That's an interesting part of
her memoirs, I can tell you.
And she sat within a grouping,
a generation of people of different ages
and different stages,
all of whom became part of this new
and transformative political project.
A couple more here may
be known to you possibly,
but in case not,
on the left hand side, Yang Siyi ,
a cadre at this time, in the
post war years, in his 40s,
mostly based in Jinjiang,
in East Central China.
Mid-level officer, not super high,
but not a junior guy either.
And on the right hand
side there, Liu Yanjin,
the youngest of any of these people.
Born in the 1925,
just in her early 20s as the
1949 revolution approached.
Let's have a look at some of
the diary entries of Yang Siyi,
who, again, does historians a huge favor
by writing not quite day to day,
but certainly every few days
as he is engaged in the campaign
that ultimately becomes part
of the victorious campaign
for the conquest of the mainland.
And one of the things that's very obvious
from what he writes at the time is that
there was nothing natural,
nothing automatic,
about local people becoming
attracted to the CCP.
Now, historians might
say, on the one hand,
that actually, it's fairly obvious,
there's nothing natural
about that sort of thing.
But, of course, there is so much language
about the idea of the masses
being naturally attracted
to this transformative social force
that swept away the hated Kuomintang...
You can fill in the words for yourself.
It's well worth noting that
the day to day experience was
clearly often quite different.
One of many very interesting entries,
from October 1945,
is when Yang Siyi takes part in count
of personnel and weapons,
because so many people are
deserting at that point
from the base area that
he's in, in Jinjiang,
as part of the newly
formed Communist armies.
They end up at that particular point
with several hundred people,
out of about 2,000 troops, deserting.
Yang observing, as he said,
"Because of the changes
in their life situation,"
in other words, being recruited and placed
in this military formation,
"everyone got quite worried."
And then, he adds the following note.
"The majority are good comrades.
"There are many reasons for such
"a serious reduction of numbers,"
by which he means desertion,
"but the leaders and the
section chiefs have not united,
"the warlord residue of
their leadership style
"and their emotional complicity,"
i.e dragging people
basically into projects
that they don't fully
agree with or approve of,
"are the main reasons.
"The military leaders and
"the political commanders
don't get on well,"
and of course, the
question of political links
and military links in the top leadership,
and also the kind of next level down
of the People's Liberation Army,
as it formed under that
name and reformed itself,
is one of the most interesting things
in terms of how you bring together
often very disparate groups of people
and turn them into an
effective fighting force,
but also political force.
So he says, "the military leaders
"and the political
commanders don't get on well,
"and this reflects abnormality
"between the party and the masses."
And I think that's both an interesting
and indeed, quite honest statement,
because much of what
then takes place in...
This is 1945, as you see,
what happens during much of
the next two, three, four years is
a continuing attempt to try
and make sure that there is some way
in which as the military
situation improves,
the political socialization
of those both in the PLA
and associated with the
PLA becomes much stronger
because their point of contrast,
of course, is the increasing collapse
of the Kuomintang armies,
and the records that we have
from people recruited in
those at lower levels are
very much of increasing realization
of lack of organization,
corruption, and failure
to ultimately achieve their various ends.
And the monitoring of the political,
ideological, and indeed,
emotional temperature
of the charges of a PLA
officer like Yang Siyi is
of course, very different in
all sorts of obvious ways,
from the process (speaking
foreign language),
entry into the party in the present day.
But the overall aim,
the aim to try and make sure
that the political and the emotional
and the professional
are brought together is
in some ways a very, very similar one,
even though today, for the most part,
it's not in a military context.
Even though, of course,
the ethos of militarization is
one of the things that
we have noted has become
much stronger in Chinese civil society
and the media sphere
in the last few years.
And Yang Siyi himself
also did something that,
again, from what we know
about party practice today,
is still very current,
which is self-reflection.
His partner was a performer
in the entertainment division of the PLA
and the relationship was not
always going terribly well.
And he writes about himself in his diary,
"I suddenly felt that
my life was very narrow
"and quite depressing."
He says, "these petit bourgeois
feelings being too thick,"
or too intense, "it's not good.
"I wanna change that in myself."
Now, to those of us sitting here
in an Anglophone country in the 2020s,
talking about your own petit
bourgeois feelings sounds,
at best, artificial,
and possibly even slightly ludicrous.
The point here is that for someone
who was feeling something that was
clearly emotionally quite genuine,
in this context, the appropriate
way to express it was
through a particular type of,
as in this case,
Marxist-influenced political language
that helped him to both express,
and process, and justify,
what it is that he wanted to do.
And this became a much
more common practice
throughout the whole of
the political project
of that particular era.
In mid-July of that year, 1946,
Yang reflected further on what
he called his two big flaws.
And he says, "When someone hurts
"my petit bourgeois self regard,
"I lose patience,
"or at least I feel unhappy inside."
The answer, as far as he was concerned,
was, as he put it,
"political study and
daily self reflection,"
which combines both
Marxism and Confucianism,
I think, in a rather effective way.
And the idea of course of
(speaking foreign language),
which Liu Shaoqi, amongst
other top communists,
was very, very keen on,
is of course, in many ways,
an inheritance of that Confucian learning,
which many of the older leaders of
the CCP had gone through at that time.
At one point, as Yang Siyi puts it,
he says, "We should read books
"just as often as we sweep the floor."
And with a rather Mao-like
analogy to bodily function,
he then adds,
"I feel that my..."
This is Yang, again.
"I feel that petit bourgeois weakness
"and self regard is like the stinkyness
"of my toes,
"it's hard to wash away."
So while I have no direct primary evidence
of what Yang Siyi's socks were like,
I think at least we can
assume that they may have been
a little overly ideologically fervid
in this particular case.
Let me give you also a few thoughts
from Liu Yanjin, the young woman.
Born in 1923,
a member, actually, also one of
those CCP military performance troops,
and deeply in love with
a man who actually became
a rather famous Chinese
movie director, Ling Zifeng,
who then married someone else.
And the diary, it is a contemporary diary,
is very moving in many ways,
but also, you can tell that it's written
by someone in her 20s
at a moment of deep emotional distress.
One of the moments that she found
very, very inspiring though was
aftermath of the Japanese defeat,
where she says, "(speaking
foreign language),"
"Oh boy, amazing.
"Faced with this victory..."
She's writing to herself,
she refers to herself
in the second person.
She says, "the party needs
you to advance more quickly,
"take on more glorious tasks.
"It does not need your
pessimistic sighing."
And later on, she writes
that, in her case,
"My petit bourgeois romantic fantasies
"and inappropriate thoughts
should be put on the shelf."
And she cite there, actually,
an often quoted, slightly misquoted, take,
which is the Leninist theory
of the glass of water,
which you may know,
which is basically a
slightly parodied version
that then put forward the
thoughts of Alexandra Kollontai,
one of the early feminist
Bolshevik thinkers.
That, supposedly, love and
relationships should be
as ordinary as drinking a glass of water,
or drinking from a bottle.
In other words, in a
truly socialist society,
it wouldn't become the
source of this huge,
romantic petit bourgeois
source of distress
or overly emotional work that it is
in a petit bourgeois society.
This is, in fact, a slight parody,
to be honest, of what Kollontai said,
but that's not so important
in this particular case.
And yet when Liu Yanjin's love
affair goes horribly wrong,
when her intended marry's someone else,
she writes a furious entry
in her diary at the time.
And I think on international
women's day, in fact,
in March 1946.
And amongst the things that she writes,
along the kind of things
that you might expect
from someone who's been
deeply hurt in love,
such as "What kind of demon
is troubling your mind?"
She says, "why don't you have
"a Bolshevik morality about love?
"You should use a robust party spirit
"to evaluate yourself."
Now, I don't know if you would write
to your angry lover, I'm not asking,
words in those terms,
but again, the fact that at this time,
in this place, in this era,
for a 20 something young woman
deeply, deeply steeped in the way
in which the party is
recasting its cadres,
to use this language about something
that's deeply personal to her
and deeply, deeply felt,
and not in any sense inauthentic.
And yet, of course, encased
in what we would regard
as Marxist jargon is
a sign of how important this recasting
of language was in terms of
people's self-definition.
Let me conclude, if I may,
with a few thoughts at the end here
about where I think some
of this comes together.
People make propaganda and ideology
to misquote Marx,
but they do not make it
exactly as they please.
In other words, it's not enough
just to understand, as we must do,
that the Kuomintang,
during the period that
we're talking about,
become immensely downhearted...
Someone like Wang Shijie,
who we started with,
just very briefly, in 1947,
he keeps writing things such as,
"I feel extremely gloomy
"about the future of the
current political situation,
"and the core people
in our party don't have
"any genuine conviction when it comes
"to democracy and
constitutional government."
The CCP diarists of that time have lots
of quite problematic things
to say, as I mentioned,
which would probably mean
that they would be guilty
of historical nihilism in the present day,
but they don't say that sort of thing.
There's a genuine emotional register
of difference between the two sides.
But beyond that,
we have to understand how
the ideological fulfillment
and sense of self creation links to
an objective reality.
And consideration of today's
nationalist propaganda
and Marxist language,
and there's plenty of it in China today,
is often treated as if it's free floating
and in some ways disconnected
from social realities.
But I think that is no more true
in the 2020s
than it was in the 1940s,
or indeed visa versa.
Language that's used today,
whether it's about
communities of common destiny
or the desire for China to be
a 21st century Marxist society,
is mostly quite inwardly directed.
It is for a Chinese audience.
But I think it is still a reminder,
the fact that it doesn't
translate very well into English
or into an international audience,
which is one of the
reasons it doesn't tend
to get used much in
China's outward propaganda,
is an nonetheless a useful
and necessary reminder
that the liberal subject is not the norm
in all societies at all times.
In other words, we can't
just translate the documents,
important though they are,
we need to understand the
reception of that language
and the use of it to construct identities
in certain ways that still have
a great deal of power.
That, in the end, I think is why
that post-war moment,
1945 to 1949,
is I think increasingly relevant
to the moment that China is in today.
As you see this that I have here,
I won't go through every
single one of them,
but in terms of some of
the practical reasons
why I think the late 1940s has
an importance for the presence of...
Sorry, the trajectory of China today,
its role at the UN,
its territorial issues,
the idea of China as a global actor,
a time of ideological
revolutionary renewal and identity,
ideas of economic development.
Moral ballast, the idea of
China as a World War II victor
that gives it a right in the world today.
All of these are things that I think,
in practical terms,
are important in linking the two periods.
But I think also, more conceptually,
the postwar era has one other element
that is reflected in something
that is very relevant to today's language.
It too was on the cusp of a new era,
one that defined politics,
or redefined politics,
in very significant ways.
And Xi Jinping of course also has defined
his period in power as a new era,
albeit one that simultaneously seeks
some kind of continuity
with the founding of
the party back in 1921,
as the resolution of last
November put forward.
And remembering that in
China, of all places,
the politics of the future is
very closely linked to interpretations
of the recent and quite distant past is,
I think, one of the many ideas
that we can draw from, to me,
that very fascinating, if
very short, postwar period.
Thank you all very much for your attention
and delighted to have
some discussion now, Arne.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much for
a wonderful, wonderful presentation.
Lots of things to discuss.
While people gather their questions,
gather their thoughts,
will I find my glasses so I can see
who wants to be heard?
I remember when I first
started looking for,
and then finding Wang
Shijie's diaries in the...
I think the (speaking foreign language).
I thought I had had a new
thesis my PhD dissertation.
I thought I'd had a major breakthrough
when I was finally able to locate them
and then get the family's
permission to actually use them.
And I came very excited
to the library one morning
and discovered most of them a written
in (speaking foreign language),
so in Engrossed script,
which, as a graduate student,
I found...
Even more so now as a professor, I guess,
I found really difficult to decipher.
So I had to call on the help of others
to try to instruct me in
the particular writing style
that he used for his diary.
But when I did get through it,
I was struck by just
how fascinating those...
And how personal those
diaries are in many ways.
Much of which was written was
when he held high political office.
But they aren't just reflecting
his political positions
and his political participation,
they're also really very introspective
in terms of what they contribute.
Maybe I could start you off
with a question of that, actually, Rana,
because...
Or connecting to the
whole issue of identity
that you bring up here.
One of the things that I've spent
quite a bit of time thinking about,
both when I was writing
on this time period
but particularly later on,
is the preoccupation with
the restitution of China
after the end of the Anti-Japanese War
as a kind of decolonization,
that you see presented
both by Republican leaders
and by communist leaders.
And this is extremely
interesting in many ways,
both because it links China
to a broader the world
of the decolonization
that was taking place at the same time.
But it's also really striking in the sense
that this is the, in many ways,
the remnants of an empire.
In the sense that both Republic of China
and the People's Republic
took over borders
that were remarkably similar to those
of the Qing Empire,
that is connecting itself to
the issue of decolonization.
So in other words, it isn't decolonization
by others that needs to be undertaken.
There is relatively little self-reflection
in terms of what actually
constitutes the Republic
that Wang Shijie and anothers
served with such eminence.
So I wonder if that is also part
of the identity challenge in a way here,
then and perhaps also now,
in terms of the use of concepts.
Not these illegal terms,
the imagination,
or the imaginary of what is
new new challenge would be.
- It's a great question, Arne, thank you.
I think one of the best case studies,
which indeed is mentioned
in Wang Shijie's diary
but has a wider purchase as well is
an event, which I think...
Oh, I think, you know more about it
than most people I think,
but which is the independence referendum
for Outer Mongolia that
takes place very early,
in late 1945.
And I think many here
will know, just to say,
it was organized by
Stalin, on Stalin's behalf.
And it had a rather miraculous result,
I think of, sort of 437,000 people
in Mongolia voted for independence
and zero people voted against it,
which was quite--
- Not a single Mongolian.
- Not a single one,
so it was entirely free
and fair in every way.
I'm sure there was soon
to be a similar vote
in Luhansk and various
other places too, as well.
But why is this interesting?
Because apart from the
astonishing nature of the vote,
which clearly was a gesture of contempt
by Stalin, in a sense,
towards the Chinese Republic in that case,
because for a very long time,
the Republic of China had continued
to maintain its claim,
that was lost in 1911
at the end of the Qing,
to Outer Mongolia,
as well as which had gone on essentially
to become a sort of
Soviet satellite state,
as a territory that
would have to be restored
to the Republic in a way that Taiwan
and various other places would do as well.
And essentially, of course, it has become
the only one of those territories
to which the Chinese state
has essentially given up
its claim during that period.
And one of the reasons
it seems to me is that
a lot of the wider discussion
during that period is
about what you can...
Essentially, what you can save
as part of a central idea of what
the Chinese Republic is going to be,
and what has to be let go.
And having to let go of Mongolia,
essentially, is a price
that can't be avoided.
And Wang Shijie himself
knows it's gonna be
very, very difficult to get past the press
and some of the more fire brand members
of the Nationalist Party
don't want to let it go too.
But because there's a
concern in particular,
the Northeast and the Northwest,
So Xinjang and Dongbei, Manchuria,
are going to come under under threat.
And in other words, eat away at that
wider territorial vision of China,
it's put forward as a
sacrifice that must be made
to save the rest in that, in that sense.
There isn't much sense, I think,
or least I have seen very little sense,
of the idea that there
should be some reckoning
with China's own record
in terms of this period.
And I'm not entirely surprised,
simply because one of the things
that I hope I've drawn
with the picture here,
and I think is evident in a
sense when one looks at it,
is that there are so many
different defensive elements
of trying to construct this state
at the same time.
And even these attempts to, I mean...
In a sense, the appeals
to Molotov and to Burns,
and to turn up in Paris
and London and say,
"We should be saying what goes
on with Italy's colonies,"
is actually part of that exercise too.
It's part of this wider claim
that actually, there is this new entity
that is a postwar China
that has a right to do
this, that, and the other.
I think there's also,
and this I'm stretching slightly
because I don't, at the
moment, have a particular quote
I could put my hand on to do that,
although perhaps I should look for one,
but I suspect there's a wrong feeling that
if the British and the
French do not resile
in any sense from their empires,
and India aside,
they really don't during this period,
and that is something that
is observed quite strongly
by the Chinese during this period.
Then the sense that looking at
the moat in their own eye is
a useful task at this point, I think,
is probably not something that's regarded
as a great political priority
at this particular stage.
But I mean, I think you're right
that it is a...
While there is lots of
insight on various things,
the sense of reflexiveness on the nature
of what exactly the
Republic is supposed to be
almost isn't given enough space
to breathe during that time, I think.
- It is quite when you think about it,
connected to other periods of transition
after great wars.
I mean, those was who read Putin's speech
in which justifies the
takeover by violence
or by armed force of Ukraine,
spends an enormous amount
of time castigating Lenin
and, to some extent, Stalin as well
for having done just that.
For thinking about Russia as an empire
in which people who were not central
to the empire actually had rights.
but you almost never
find that on the Chinese
(indistinct) Chinese Republic.
Okay, other questions?
Yes.
- [Audience Member] Hey
Rana, thank you very much.
So a non-historian facile question.
It seems to me you've skated very lightly
over the fact that we're
talking about nationalists,
not communists (indistinct).
You seem to make big, bold claim here
about cultural continuity
(indistinct) the political situation,
historical narrative, and so on,
being far more important
than socialist mindsets,
political views and everything else,
in making these comparisons
between the '40s and 2022.
Any comments?
- Actually, I thought I was
rather doing the opposite,
which is pointing out that, actually,
language and mindset makes
a huge amount of difference
at this time,
because the sort of
language that you would get
amongst these younger,
and not so young cadres,
is not at all the kind of language
that would've been used in that form
by the kind of figures
on the nationalist side,
who have their own political language
and very strong...
People like Chiang Ching-kuo,
or indeed, Wang Shijie,
or actually, Jiǎng Tíngfú,
or Chen Bulei,
Chiang Kai-shek's personal
secretary, in a sense,
who eventually takes his own life in 1948
through a complication of depression
that comes from personal
mental health issues,
but also with the collapse of the regime
around him at that time.
But much of the language
in which they express
their own growing sense
of gloom and despair is a,
as you would know, Chloe, very well,
a quite traditional sort of
Confucian self-presentation
that's, in some ways, rather rejecting
of this idea of self-realization
and changing through ideas
that come from a Marxist
framework in that sense.
I think that one of the things
that could do with more emphasis
during this particular period,
cause it's one of the rare periods
when you get not quite a even conflict,
but certainly one where there's
strong elements on both sides,
is the way in which the
post war period is one
of different sorts of political visions
that are expressed in different
sorts of political language
to socialize the people
who are putting them forward.
And one of the areas
that I didn't talk about,
partly 'cause I thought
you wouldn't all thank me
for going on for three hours,
but there's quite a lot
about land reform, actually,
the (speaking foreign language)
program during this time,
where actually lots of
these people are recording,
first of all, really interesting things
about how, again...
In retrospect, it's all
about the peasants rise up
against their evil oppressors,
and there's actually
plenty of that going on,
but also, a great deal
of it is spent in a way
that isn't always so much stressed
in communists basically giving
other communists a hard time
about not being sufficiently
indoctrinated into the program
and having the right kind of...
The wrong kind of rightist
or the right kind of leftist
viewpoint as part of that.
But the consequence of
these things were not
by any means purely abstract.
They ended in real people being locked up
or hit with bill hooks,
or murdered at their
neighbors in front of the...
In front of other farmers.
So these things have a real context
in that sense.
Does that get to the question
or was that to so...
Yup, yup, yup.
- [Arne] Yes.
- [Audience Member] Thank you for this
really stimulating talk,
I really enjoyed it.
I wanted to ask you maybe to reflect
a bit more on this concept
of the Chinese postwar,
and particularly the end date for it,
which it sounds like
you're sticking with 1949.
- Oh no, no, no, no,
no, no, absolutely not.
So thank you for (indistinct) that.
But sorry, finish your question.
- [Audience Member] Maybe that's
enough to let you go there
'cause I was wondering, first,
how much it does actually
differ from the civil war.
Is this just another way of thinking
about the civil war period, (indistinct)?
But then the other part,
I'm a Japan specialist
and I've been thinking
comparatively as you were talking,
and one thing that I think comes up
a lot in the Japanese case is
the endless debates about when
the postwar actually ends?
- Yes, when does (speaking
foreign language) actually end?
Do you have the answer to that?
'Cause I don't.
- [Audience Member] Well,
and I think, one thing,
it varies a lot by geography.
Like, Okinawa's postwar is very different
than mainland Japan's postwar,
and Sakhalin and the
Kuril Islands' postwar is
still ongoing (indistinct) or whatever.
But it's also a historical question
that comes up again again, again.
Is it the occupation?
Is it the Olympics?
Is it the oil crisis?
Is it the death of the (indistinct)?
And so on and so forth.
And so, I'm wondering,
maybe that's too much to, I realize,
(indistinct) trying to
address all of that,
but I was wondering how much you see 1949,
or perhaps some other date,
as a moment when kind of
all of the stuff gets put
on hold for a while and we
enter kind of a different period
of the Cultural Revolution
or the Maoist period or whatever,
or whether you see sort of continuities
in certain areas of China
or certain areas of Chinese politics?
That's very open ended, I've realized,
but if you could talk
a bit more about that,
I'd appreciate it.
- No, I'd be very happy to do that,
and it's a great question.
I mean, just as...
I mean, I think one level,
just as you've said, the
Japanese (indistinct),
or indeed the European
postwar doesn't have
an obvious endpoint,
and indeed, whether the Russian
assault on Ukraine is going
to prove, as many people are saying,
the end of a particular
sort of postwar order is
something we're debating,
as we speak right to right now.
I think the answer is it's certainly...
I personally don't intend it to be 1949.
It's not meant to be literally
just the four years
(murmurs) after period.
But I do think of it as something
that obviously has the
civil war at heart of it,
because how could it not?
But that stretches beyond that,
at least into the mid-1950s.
I think the idea of it is this,
that the forces that are unleashed
by the circumstances of the very long war
with Japan are not worked through,
certainly by 1949.
I mean, in a sense,
many of the things that
emerge at that point,
not least the split between
the mainland and Taiwan,
are products of the
forces that are unleashed
at that particular time.
But one of the things that I
think new work is beginning to
really get to grips with is
the idea that, in some ways,
the fact that you have
these split jurisdictions
and legitimacies between
the mainland and Taiwan
really matter in some
quite important ways.
I mean, I think I can say,
without specifically (murmurs) things,
but I think there's
gonna be a postdoc coming
to Arne's program during next year
whose doctoral thesis I
examined at Cambridge University
and is a fascinating study of,
in particular, the way
in which various types
of communist and anti
communist legitimacy are sought
in the global south,
or third world, you might say,
by Taiwan and the PRC.
I think the idea that perhaps existed
even a little while ago
that once it was on the island,
the Taiwan government had no time
or interest in anything except trying
to shore up its own position
and oppressing dissidents;
both of which it did do to
a very extensive extent.
But also, had really quite
a strong idea of itself
as an actor in the world,
an actor that was part of
an anti-communist front,
an actor that was still
a postcolonial actor
in its own right.
So hence the connections with all
these slightly dodgy folk,
likes Syngman Rhee and
Bao Dao, and so forth,
continue to be important.
And also, actually,
an alternative economic actor as well.
One of the great ironies of the postwar is
that land reform under Chiang
Kai-Shek goes really well.
It's just, it goes really well on Taiwan
with American support,
once he's actually got
away from the mainland,
where it'd have been an
absolute disaster on his part.
And land reform of very different sort is
then offered in the mainland
as a challenge to Asia,
and indeed beyond Asia, as well,
as in Vietnam and other parts of
an emergent revolutionary
in Southeast Asia.
Even for some time into the 1950s,
the colonial challenge
to the Republic of China,
as indeed to the People's
Republic is still there.
Malaysia doesn't become
independent until 1957.
You have Vietnam Wars,
first with the French, and
then with the Americans,
and then indeed with
the Chinese, eventually.
In other words, all of the agendas
that shape the global postwar,
or even the global Cold
War, I suppose, Arne,
continue to be of relevance
to the political projects
that are underway both
in the mainland of China
and in Taiwan,
even if they're not
always of equal valency
and equal significance.
But they both matter at that time
because they're in that world,
making the case,
and also pushing forward agendas
that clearly suit them better than...
Better than their opponent.
- [Arne] That is a person that
a personality discussion in itself.
Yes.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you so much for that talk.
(indistinct) two questions.
The first question regarding your...
I think the question regarding
the (indistinct).
And I was wondering,
I'm very much convinced of their, I guess,
the self-reflection
they're trying to practice
in their Republic.
The question is, how much do
we see this kind of process
as they're being part of the product
from the young years,
when the young campaign
was just kind of started
in '42 to '45?
And given that, I think there
has this part of continuity,
I was wondering, how much can we see
as kind of independent of the
(indistinct) process themselves,
or gradually kind of a
byproduct of the process
during the Yang campaign
and during the kind of the (indistinct)?
The second question is, I feel,
I guess, you have been discussing
the nationalist for (indistinct)
and all sorts the communist cultures,
and I wonder, during the postwar,
there's also the third pass intellectual,
they're kind of debates,
(indistinct) the future of China--
- So Zhang Junmai, and
those sorts of people.
- [Audience Member] The question is like,
how do I say less kind
of intellectual debates
as part of, I guess,
the legacy of continuity
that we have?
(indistinct)?
- You have two great questions, thanks.
Well, let me try and briefly...
Sorry, I know we're
getting to time as well,
but I'll try and give a brief answer
to each of them.
I think, in the first...
And I think you're absolutely right.
I don't think with these sorts of very,
very strongly committed revolutionaries.
It certainly doesn't begin
in the postwar period.
They have this very long engagement
with the revolution from
their teenage years,
from the 1920s and 30s onwards.
And again, I didn't have remotely
enough time to talk about
it, but each of the...
Well, in particular, Zeng Zhi,
but also, to some extent, Liu Yanjin,
they have long and quite
complex personal lives,
as with all revolutionaries
that are linked with their
revolutionary lives as well.
And one of the elements, again,
that I only talked about in passing,
but in the study that I'm doing, I think,
has in a sense become
more important for me is
the perhaps not surprising,
and somewhat depressing,
but nonetheless necessary discovery,
historically necessary discovery,
that gender really makes a difference.
The experience of young
revolutionary women
in the 1930s and 40s,
even ones like Zeng Zhi,
who run off in their teenage years
and are taking part in some
pretty violent activities,
are still given a much harder time
by party leaders than young men
in that particular position,
and that becomes visible
over and over again.
So I think in terms of that structure,
I'd say it's certainly
very long term thing,
but actually, gender is yet
another one of the frameworks
that I think shapes that experience,
and that's why I thought
it was very important
to make sure that at least
a significant amount of the
revolutionary experience
that one considers during this period is
from women as well as from men.
In terms of that third
force of intellectuals,
I mean, I've been doing some reading
on some of the people...
One of the people who, again,
is very well known,
but sometimes some of his
specifics are not always studied
as they might, partly
cause he wrote so much,
is Liang Shu-ming.
And Liang Shu-ming, he...
Because in a sense,
for English-speaking scholarly readers,
he's been characterized
as "The Last Confucian,"
Guy Alitto's famous book.
But in a sense, he is that,
but he's much more as
well, in various ways.
And one of the interesting things,
and again, Arne, because
you know everything
on (indistinct),
but when Liang Shu-ming takes this flight
to meet Mao and these other guys
while they're still in Yenan, about 1946,
and sort of has a long chat with them.
And there's this wonderful scene
in which Liang Shu-ming
explains, in great detail,
this very, very complex political system
that he thinks is going to navigate
between Western-style government,
which he doesn't think
is gonna work in China,
and a Bolshevik-style government,
which he doesn't think
is gonna work in China,
and the Kuomintang,
which he hates as well and
thinks that's not gonna work.
And it involves lots...
He makes comparisons with what's happening
in the United Nations,
which is just being set up at that time,
and what you can take from various
traditional Chinese things.
Anyway, takes a long time.
He's talking to Mao Zedong,
he's talking to Zhu De,
he's talking to lots of top people.
And then at the end, he stops,
and this is his own recollection of it,
so he's telling against himself.
And there's just silence,
and all these top communist
leaders are staring at him.
And then, finally, I think
it's actually Zhu De, says,
"Ah, so it took you 30 years
to work that out, did it?"
And they turn onto other
subjects quite quickly.
So there's definitely
a willingness to hear,
but whether or not people actually react
to some of these people, I think,
unfortunately is not as
obvious in that case.
But it's interesting to see the efforts
that they made.
And I think that they were
by no means, as really,
as needful of being dismissed
as they sometimes are.
They were an important part
of a much richer debate
than sometimes realized.
- [Arne] I think we'll
take one more question,
if there's one.
Let us go with two.
(indistinct), first.
- [Audience Member] (indistinct)
- I'm just gonna come
forward a little bit.
- [Audience Member] Sorry,
I need to speak louder.
So I think it's fascinating that
you were able to work with a lot of
personal writings and diaries.
And my question is,
because I know diary writing
for that time period is
not just like a personal habit,
but was also required by law institutions,
by military schools.
So I'm just wondering when we work
with this kinda sources as historians,
how do acknowledge the background
and some potential bias
that they might have,
and how do you deal with
that in your research?
Thank you so much.
- [Arne] Could we do these two together?
- Let's get them together, absolutely.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank for your talk.
Actually, my question is
similar to (indistinct).
I was thinking about the use...
Both the use of diaries in this talk,
and also the juxtaposition of diaries.
In some ways, all of them
are about calling into being
a new kind of world,
whether it's a kinda global order
or a new kind self-identification.
So I'd also like to ask you to speak more
about the choice of the diaries,
the use of the diaries,
and then what is
the audience for the diaries?
And then, I guess the larger question, is
how...
(indistinct)
How is the act of writing
different from the act of speaking?
And how is writing and being
this vision of the world
different from speaking it and being?
- Great, thanks.
Two wonderful questions to finish off with
in related areas.
I mean, no diaries, or
no personal accounts,
of any sort are, in any sense,
pure, or unmediated, or authentic.
Everything is constructed
in some particular idea.
And one of the reasons I gave
a quick drive by shooting
to the idea of the liberal subject,
and hey, I'm a liberal subject,
I love the liberal subject,
is that we do...
"We," university-educated,
Ivy League type people,
living in the Western
world, speaking English,
tend to assume it's normative
and that other things are deviations
or anomalies from them,
e.g. the construction of the mind of
a young communist cadre in the 1940s.
So part of what I was trying
to do is point out that...
Not that there's any sense in which
these things are not constructed.
I mean, part of the answer
to her question is that
at that time,
one of the ways in which you're expected
to self-discipline is to
write personal accounts.
And particularly, in the case of
mid-level cadres and others,
they would quite often be read,
and inspected, and discussed
by senior officers elsewhere as well.
So the idea that this were purely
private documents wouldn't
necessarily be the case.
I would recommend, by the way,
the fantastic book "Writing War,"
or by Aaron Moore, Aaron William Moore,
which is about different types of Chinese,
Japanese, and indeed, American
service people's diaries,
service men's diaries, mostly,
and how they are used
to try and both mediate
through a professional obligation
and a sense of creation of the self.
But I think one of the things...
I mean, I think the answer to it...
The other answer to your question is,
how can we kind of use them productively?
I think it's true as of
all these sorts of sources
that you have to read against the grain,
and there's the phrase that
has become the Stockholm,
but it's useful in this sense.
And in particular case,
the things that I think
they're useful for are things
like understanding where the flaws
and difficulties in the
revolution come about,
that are later smoothed out by the idea
that actually everything
that party does goes well
and that everyone follows
the revolutionary path.
And one of the things that is clearest
across these very different diaries
from different people in
different parts of China
at various times is that the revolution,
surprise, surprise,
was not a smooth and easy process
and had a lot of complexities within it
during that time.
But the one thing I think
we probably can't do,
and we can, I think, take pride in having
to work around this is that
unlike Leopold von Ranke,
the idea of (speaking foreign language),
"how it really was,"
that isn't really what
people's construction
of themselves does
because everything is going to be mediated
through a set of positions,
whether it's gender or class
or geography or emotion,
which I think is one of
the really important ones.
It is really different
reading diary entrances
from Chen Bulei,
who's a senior man who is suffering
a mental health issue that
eventually will help him...
Force him to take his own life,
and the work, or the writings,
of a 22 year old woman who is having
a very, very bad personal
life experience at that time,
in terms of her relationship,
but on the other hand is
part of what she perceives,
and repeatedly defines
herself as being part of,
an ongoing transformative project
of which she's very
enthusiastic to be a part.
And all these things are visible
in terms of the way in which
they present themselves,
but they're not simply capable, I think,
of being separated out as being
either sort of positive or negative,
or supportive or unsupportive,
of a particular political project.
That they're more complex than that.
- Thank you very much, Rana.
I was also thinking about
the gender dimensions,
so they actually discussed it in
my research seminar a couple of weeks ago.
And the significance for
trying to understand theories
of tremendous change,
like the one that you are dealing with,
it drew being able to
listen to women's voices
from indifferent positions,
and different situations.
And often, even today,
that is not done.
I mean, it was already
things that struck me
when I worked on the
civil war era in China,
what a period of breakthroughs
for women that was.
I mean, in organizational terms,
but also, in much broader terms.
In intellectual life,
in terms of what went
on in the countryside.
So maybe we could have you back
when this project is nearing completion
(speaking over each other)
- I mentioned another, another
dimension (indistinct).
But first of all,
thank you very much for a
wonderful lecture today.
(audience applauding)